You think about Canada
accepting 1 million immigrants every year.
Do you think it's beautiful?
I think the current immigration policy,
I think there are
too many immigrants coming into Canada currently.
Think a lot of immigrants are not fleeing from war
and I think a lot are just coming to Canada
cause it does have better opportunities over
that means Canadians who were born and raised here
are not getting the opportunities they should be.
And I think that Canada could keep accepting war
immigrants and what not
and people that need humanitarian aid.
However, at this point,
there's too many immigrants coming on,
coming into Canada,
causing housing crisis,
prices to go up because Chido
is slowing down permits to build more houses
and he's allowing more immigrants to come.
So more people,
less houses,
higher prices for homes.
So I think that we should slow down immigration
and it needs to be reworked.
As always, we have to, uh,
do what's right for the country,
right? So housing is an issue.
People are coming here
and they're not able to find housing or afford housing.
These are things that have to be,
you know, looked at and, and,
and adjust it
because it has to make sense for the country
and for the economy.
That's the most important thing.